hi guys how you doing great you were
nominated tonight we do know
didn't work out in your favor but you
were nominated
semi-nominated almost I was I was on a
nominated album but we're claiming that
we're claiming yeah for sure big deal it
is a big deal right
and you two are a big deal I mean
you look she's blushing is this that
means seriously it's like you know date
night out tonight yeah 100 yeah good
night to just have fun the two of us
you have a favorite Grammy memory
because your dad has made some like
incredible Grammy memory yeah I mean
I've definitely I've seen him I've seen
him uh do several performances last year
I think he did he did it with uh her
yeah yeah I think I think that one was
great um also like
hello Cool J I know he did one with him
years ago I don't know I feel like
they've always been great
okay so who are you looking forward to
seeing tonight Charlie oh my goodness I
mean there's so many amazing artists
here I saw Doja cat was here on was
looking on Twitter seeing who was here
um it's just there's so many amazing
people I'm kind of excited to see
everyone you know haven't been out in a
while so this should be fun you guys not
only on your dating you're like blending
the world of reality TV royalty here for
you guys yeah honestly I mean you have a
new stepmama how's everything been it's
been amazing yeah it's been great she's
awesome you know you're a lot they're
love it gives me hope I mean they are so
in love it's really great yeah I know it
is it's inspiring yeah there you go see
take channel that love that you see your
daddy giving and you give it 100 yeah
y'all have a great time tonight okay
good to see you guys
[Music]